today on the Matt Walsh show a Democrat
senator claims that the United States
invented slavery this seems to be a
common view on on the left and it's
nonsense of course an honest look at
history shows that white people
Americans or Europeans certainly didn't
invent slavery and don't carry unique
guilt for the sin of slavery so today I
wanna I want to since since they brought
it up I want to have an honest
conversation about slavery and take an
honest look at the history of it I think
that's important to do if we want to be
if we want to understand it and its
legacy and it's a effect on people today
that we need to take an honest look at
it we're gonna do that today also five
headlines including a vicious assault on
an elderly woman by a man who has been
arrested up to a hundred times already
this guy's walking around been arrested
a hundred times already and that and now
is assaulting old women and in our daily
cancellation I will be canceling the
public apology we have we have seen
yesterday we saw maybe the worst public
apology yet and I think it's time to
cancel public apologies altogether all
of that coming up but we begin with this
Democrat senator Tim Kaine proved
yesterday that Millennials are not the
only ones who've never read a history
book when he stood on the floor of the
Senate to denounce America's invention
of slavery here's what he had to say we
need to ban racial and religious
profiling we need to hold police
officers and police departments
accountable for violent reckless
behavior we need to promote better
training and professional accreditation
of police departments Madam President
why do we demand that universities
maintain accreditation and receive
federal funds but make no such demand of
law enforcement agencies and we need to
do much more within the criminal justice
system but also within all of our
systems to dismantle the structures of
racism that our federal state and local
governments carefully erected and
maintained over centuries we know a
little bit about this in Virginia the
first African Americans and into the
English colonies came to Point Comfort
Virginia in 1619 they were slaves
they've been captured against their
we'll but they landed in colonies that
didn't have slavery there were no laws
about slavery in the colonies at that
time the United States didn't inherit
slavery from anybody we created it it
got created by the Virginia General
Assembly and the Legislature's of other
states it got created by the court
systems in colonial America and sense
that enforced Fugitive Slave laws it was
we created it and we created it and
maintained it over centuries and in in
my lifetime we have finally stopped some
of those practices but we've never gone
back to undo it
stopping racist practices at your 350 or
400 years but then taking no effort to
dismantle them is not the same as truly
combating racism but I'm mindful of the
challenge laid down by our young people
no more politics as usual yeah you gotta
love when politicians who've been in
office since like the war of 1812 come
out and denounce politics as usual
enough politics as usual you want to
talk about who invented things these are
the people who invented politics as
usual you are politics as usual but
anyway Kaine says the United States
didn't inherit slavery from anybody we
created it tracing our alleged creation
of slavery back to 1619 over 150 years
before the United States actually was
founded the most generous possible
interpretation of this seemingly
incoherent remark is that the United
States created slavery in the United
States so this would be true of course
in a certain way but by this by the same
logic you could say that the United
States created the wheel and irrigation
and agriculture and Chinese food right
in that none of these things existed in
the United States before the United
States existed in other words the United
States created its own version of all
these things in in a certain way you
might say that would be an accurate
statement but also weirdly redundant and
unnecessary and when it comes to the
good stuff like you know irrigation and
the wheel and other
innovations you would never hear someone
like tim kaine try to give us credit for
inventing those things in any sense at
all yeah with slavery he's gonna do that
the more obvious and direct
interpretation of the of Tim Kane's
remarks there is that he believes or at
least wants us to believe that the
institution of slavery itself was
designed and implemented originally by
Americans and many people in this
country especially college students
really do seem to be under that
impression I would wager that if you
went to one of these protests and polled
the protesters 90% of them would would
say that slavery is unique to America or
at least Europeans in fact a university
professor a few years ago wrote
something talking about he pulled he
pulled students or for years he had been
polling polling students on their
historical knowledge and he found that a
vast majority of the students hold this
very belief that slavery is unique to
our country and that we carry almost all
of the blame for it as white Americans
this is the message sent loud and clear
by the mobs tearing down statues and BLM
activists demanding that white people
kneel and apologize before them and
leftists who degrade Western
civilization and its achievements white
Westerners it is said have a unique
reason to apologize they are they are
the descendants of history's greatest
villains and any any discussion of
historical atrocities should begin and
end with them that's the way it normally
goes and this again is nonsense for one
thing before we even get into this
history of slavery nobody is responsible
for the actions of their ancestors and
and one man cannot and should not
apologize to another man for events that
occurred before both of them were born
apology is not the way to go to
apologize to something is to take
responsibility for if you apologize for
something you're taking responsibility
for it you're taking ownership of it but
you obviously cannot take responsibility
and ownership of things that were done
at a time when you didn't exist clearly
we could discuss the legacy of these
events we could discuss how they still
affect people today but nobody involved
in the conversation
today has any reason for guilt or
remorse with respect to slavery empathy
and understanding are one thing and a
good thing but there is nothing good
about falling to your knees and begging
forgiveness for actions you never took
and decisions that you never made at
best this is performative
self-flagellation at worst it is sincere
and delusional self-loathing either way
in either case it is not healthy and it
is not good for another thing the United
States did not invent slavery or racism
by the way white Europeans didn't invent
it either
if the guilt of slavery can be inherited
from one generation to another I don't
think it can but if it can be then we've
all inherited it we are all stained by
nobody nobody in that case would be
innocent the institution of slavery goes
back ten thousand years or more to the
Neolithic Revolution as long as human
society has had agriculture it has had
slaves forced to do the work and as we
just established America didn't invent
agriculture either either the soil on
every continent on earth except for
Antarctica has been tilled by slaves
everywhere slavery was a common in
almost unquestioned practice everywhere
all over the world among nearly all
people for thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of years
now if Europeans did not invent slavery
can they be at least blamed for the
formation of the slave trade you hear
that sometimes well no slaves were
traded as commodities as far back as
ancient Egypt or before for centuries
before the transatlantic slave trade
Arab traders would conduct their own
raids
into into Africa and they would capture
African villagers and ship them back to
the Arabian Peninsula for sale was
slavery in the United States or the
colonies more brutal or more inhumane
than other iterations of the practice
again no no it was brutal and inhumane
yes but it would be hard to argue that
it was worse morally than the forms of
slavery common across the globe for
example in the sub-saharan slave trade
established about thousand years before
the United States came into being so you
know 700 years 700 or 800 ad young boys
were routinely castrated and then and
then sold into forced labor in Asia
Middle East or within Africa itself it's
worth noting speaking of slavery in
Africa that slavery in Africa was not
fully abolished on the continent until
1981 that that's when the last African
country abolished slavery
can we at least blame Americans or
Europeans for bringing slavery to North
America you know when we're looking for
the unique guilt
part of it is that where we can go can
we say that ok they brought us in North
America before you know they sullied and
stained in North America with with
slavery whereas before it didn't exist
once again no slavery was commonplace in
the Americas well before European
settlers showed up well before Native
American tribes enslaved each other
often by conquest and capture this was a
normal part of the culture in life of
many Native American tribes now those
who wish to make the practice lavery
practiced by Europeans seem appreciably
worse than other forms will often
claimed that Native American slavery was
more humane and that it wasn't permanent
and those sorts of things now this may
be true in some cases but certainly not
all in you know in the Mesoamerica
region a slave may have escaped slavery
you know say his term of slavery may
have come to an end
at a certain point but oftentimes his
period of enslavement would end when he
was ritualistically butchered as a human
sacrifice which was a widespread
practice in the region for hundreds of
years don't listen anyone who tells you
that human sacrifice in this part of the
world was was was uncommon or it had you
know sort of a fringe practice happened
every once a while it was a common part
of life across that part of the world
for hundreds of years
you know the the chimú in modern-day
Peru carried out the worst mass
sacrifice of children ever to occur on
earth as far as we know up to this point
over a hundred and forty children were
slaughtered probably by having their
hearts ripped out of their chests while
they were still alive we know about this
because we found recently the mass
graves of all the children in an in
another particularly grisly episode the
Aztecs killed and dismembered 84,000
human beings in four days to christen
the new temple that had just been
erected 84,000 people think about that
in four days and this is before they had
modern weaponry this is one of the worst
mass slaughters ever conducted anywhere
on earth at any point in history and
they did it without modern weaponry you
just think about the the brutality of
that and not just brutality but this the
systematic brutality think about how
systematic and efficient you would have
to be in killing people to kill 84,000
people by hand in four days now granted
not all of these sacrifices would have
been slaved but the point is that this
was not a civilization unfamiliar with
brutality and inhumanity to put it
mildly
in fact Native Americans took part in
African slavery as well they don't you
know says this is a part of another
another aspect of history they're gonna
tell you about in schools because they
don't tell you much by the time of the
Civil War fifteen percent of the
Cherokee population was comprised of
black slaves and Indian tribes could be
quite brutal to their black slaves as
well in one case in one documented case
just as an example black slave named
lucy was accused of murder and then
burned alive by an angry mob of Choctaws
because she was it was it was claimed
that she had killed someone okay so this
is the kind of treatment that black
slaves in Native American tribes could
could expect to receive I'm not arguing
that the slavery practiced by white
Americans was you know less bad just
because everybody else was doing it so
it was one of the first things you learn
as a kid just because everyone's doing
something doesn't make it okay
especially when it's one of the most
horrific evils in the history of mankind
slavery doesn't make it okay because
everyone's doing it slavery in America
was a horrid abomination which is why we
rightly celebrate its abolition an
abolition that that came we should note
only 90 years after the formation of the
country the United States as a nation
had legal slavery for less than a
century now for comparison's sake China
had slavery for 3,000 years before it
was officially abolished and that didn't
happen until the 20th century and
unofficially it goes on to this very day
in China and in many other parts of the
world in fact this again does not lessen
the brutality of American slavery
doesn't mitigate the evil of the
institution but it does go to show that
that the exclusive focus on slavery in
America and the insistence that white
Americans have inherited unique guilt
because of it is simply wrong and I
think that you know we have talked so
much about the legacy of slavery in this
country and the legacy of racism by by
white people in this country this is a
conversation we've had over and over
again and we will continue to have I
just think at a certain point once we've
established that there were a lot of
racist terrible white people and they
owned slaves and it was awful and you
know I think everybody agrees with that
and we're gonna continue to have that
kind I'm not even saying we should stop
having that conversation but at a
certain point can we introduce the other
civilizations on earth I mean are we
allowed to ever
bring that up if there ever comes a time
you know when we are ready to have a
mature nuanced discussion of slavery and
of racism and of their legacies in the
modern day which I think would be a very
worthwhile conversation have and I would
be eager to participate in it you know
after all we can't understand where we
are we can't understand where we're
going until we know where we've been
right this is a cliche but it's true if
you're if you don't know history are
doomed to repeat it yeah you know all
the debt we've go into all the cliches
all of them basically true but this
discussion is only possible and can only
be worthwhile if we look at history with
a wider lens if we understand the
context of the institutions and the
attitudes that we rightly reviled today
if we have already decided from the
outset that whatever happened in history
white people must have been especially
bad and the evil they committed must
have been unique to them then there's no
point we can't have a discussion it
can't go anywhere we are like children
then making reality into a cartoon but
if we are prepared to look honestly at
our history as a species and see that we
are all the descendants of deeply flawed
human beings who were often brutal and
bigoted to each other and who until very
recently had no concept of inherent
human equality and little notion of
racial tolerance but who also struggled
mightily and made great sacrifices and
achieved great things for our sake then
perhaps we could have a fruitful
dialogue but only then only then when
we're ready to be mature and nuanced in
this discussion can any good come of it
and and
my point let's move on to your news
headlines for the day number one
a man named Rashid brim egde dirty
one-years-old has been arrested now for
doing this
that is a 92 year old woman that he
randomly shoved and she fell and hit her
head on a fire hydrant thank God it
looks like she's gonna be okay but
physically at least maybe not
emotionally bridge though was an old
veteran of getting arrested he's been
he's been you know down this road many
times before depending on which news
report you've read he's been arrested
already anywhere between 60 and 100
times for oftentimes serious crimes he's
a sex offender on top of it and he's
still walking around so with you know
with all this focus on them even even
from from Trump would police reform and
prison reform how about this problem how
about the problem of having violent
sociopaths still walking around in our
communities despite the fact that we
know that they're violent sociopaths and
they've already been arrested before for
it how about the problem of the system
of the prison system the court system
releasing back into the public people
who it knows are dangerous and who it
knows will almost certainly victimize
more people in the future how about that
problem why not some focus on that how
about some focus on that from from
conservatives I wasn't focused on that
from from Trump and I don't just mean
tweeting law and order in all caps like
an impotent weakling and then you go out
and you know the first thing it does
yesterday gives us an executive order on
police reform you think that's the main
thing we need right now how about an
executive order designating an Tifa a
domestic terrorist organization
I mean for all the credit this guy gets
right is that he doesn't appease the
left he appeases the left all the time
that's that's the dirty little secret
about Donald Trump he doesn't appease
them with his tweets sure but with what
he'd what he does with his actual
actions he's constantly appeasing them
and it's not just them it there are very
few people who have the courage to talk
about this problem which is crazy
because it's it's one of the most
popular positions you could actually
take it might not be popular with the
morons in the media and with far-left
activists and it might not be popular
with the you know the black lives matter
organization or antifa but with with
just with just average citizens taking a
position that dangerous violent known
sociopaths who have already committed
crimes should be off of our streets
permanently that's a position that would
get widespread approval from from nearly
every average normal citizen instead we
get prison reform police reform that's
everything we're trying to reform this
isn't some kind of isolated incident
okay it's alec Rasheed brim äj--
is the only dangerous violent known
sociopath walking around the streets
casually committing crimes because he
has no conscience and no soul there are
there are many in this category because
we would have one out to talk about all
the you know how how supposedly inhumane
and brutal our court system is you know
it's I think it's it's normally inhumane
and brutal to the citizens which is
supposed to be protecting releasing them
back into the public you want more
examples of that just go look at your
sex offender registry look at your look
at your local sex offender registry to
see where all the sex offenders are in
your neighborhood if you haven't done
that you should do it if you have kids
and what you're gonna find are you have
a lot of people that are flagged as
being high risk sex offenders who have
committed violent sexual crimes often
times against children and they're in
the community you know they're just
living down the street the hell they do
it in the commute why aren't they behind
bars forever
why do you ever
let them out now if there's any justice
Rasheed Bremen on his 100th arrest or
60th arrest whatever it is you lose
count at a certain point if there's any
justice at all this would be it for him
he would never see the outside of a
prison cell ever again but there's no
justice we know he'll be back on the
show if he's not already out on bail
he'll you know what he'll get maybe a
couple years in jail maybe if not a
suspended sentence probation that's
what's gonna happen number two I just I
want to show you this I think you'll be
inspired by it it's by it same as I was
here's a tweet from Joe Biden it says we
need a president who chooses unity over
division Wow that is remarkable
real bravery there you know to come out
and say I just I want I thought it
deserves on headline to have someone
who's willing to come out and say that
who's willing to say you know what I
want unity not division I'm Pro unity
anti division great stuff
this is why we need this guys president
number three the hill reports several
major airlines are moving to end or
temporarily suspend some alcoholic
beverage services in response to the
corner virus outbreak CNN reported that
several European airlines as well as
Delta and American Airlines are moving
to cutback on service of alcohol
beverages both Delta and American
Airlines have ended beverage services on
domestic flights while some
international flights may see services
restricted as well they're basically
just trying to make the flying
experience these airlines they get
together you know I'm convinced they get
together in a room you know it's like a
conspiracy and they do this once a month
or once every two months and they just
think of additional things they can do
to make flying as miserable for everyone
involved as miserable as it as it
possibly can be and they're very
innovative in that way you almost
respect it so this is just the latest in
that effort number four now let's check
in with the autonomous zone in Seattle
well let's just see what's going on over
there here's here's the latest
[Music]
okay there it is that's what they're
doing nothing wrong with that orange
peel over the face doing karate at an
imaginary person nothing wrong with I
won't judge you no got to spend the time
somehow
number five finally I know I already
inspired you with the Joe Biden thing
but I wanted to inspire you again if you
don't mind if you tolerate being
inspired twice in the span of just a
couple of minutes might be a little bit
of an overload but my friend Allie
Stuckey reached out a few days ago and
she said she was putting this together
more plate four in a second but she had
this project in mind she wanted to put
it together and she asked me if I'd be a
partially explained it to me said be a
part of it and I listened and I just
knew right away that it was something
that I needed to be involved in and I'm
gonna play this for you
now you just fair warning you might not
like everything that you hear in this
you might not like everything that we
have to say and it took frankly a lot of
boldness and courage on our part to
speak out in this way saying the things
that we say here but someone had to do
it and so that's what this is really
about it's it's about someone finally
standing up doing what needs to be done
and saying what needs to be said and
here it is imagine a world without
injustice world where we can all bravely
say injustice is bad racism is
bad bear bad like super bad until we're
there I'll be the one to stand up to
stand up and say this bad things are bad
they're awful and I don't like them I
will say something I will show I will
sing until until the bad is gone
I will fight injustice by posting a
black square a black offer solutions
solutions taking away guns or defunding
the police like telling working-class
people just to stop working to save
lives promoting socialism so no one will
ever be as rich as on finally stopping
Big Oil and the big SUV big big
companies ok but we won't stop there we
take responsibility responsibility the
only way we know how by showing how much
we hate ourselves we hate ourselves I
will I will reduce my pool time by 5
minutes a day give up chicken nuggets I
will stop wait a minute shave my
eyebrows off I'll do it just like
completely throw myself into a volcano
waterboard myself with gasoline peel my
skin off with a cheese grater and lock
myself in a box full scorpions and
launch myself into the Sun join us join
us and let's change the world
yeah I'm just gonna pause for a minute
just I you know I want to give you a
second to let that soak in to really
think about that in it's okay you know
if if you want to go back and watch it
again you can do that it's it's not
every day that you see something
life-changing and so I don't want to
trample all over it but so let's just
let's just take a moment pause for a
moment and really think about what you
just saw
[Music]
yeah I was just thinking about it again
I was thinking about what I said myself
and I was inspired by it myself
I sort of rien spired myself by what I
said in let me just say this because you
watch that video and you think to
yourself man these people especially
Matt let's just focus on me for a second
Matt is standing up and saying these
things you know he's getting up and
saying injustice is bad
racism is bad he's speaking out about
all the bad things okay a lot of people
are gonna speak out against one or two
bad things but he's standing up is
speaking out against every bad thing
where does he get the courage to do that
why is he so willing to put himself on
the line in this way I know that's what
you think I said that's the question
you're asking and you're thinking
yourself is he a hero you know you see
one of history's great heroes the answer
says yes but I don't want you to think
about the Kurd some yes there's a lot of
courage involved but here's what I want
you understand about me okay and this is
my humility talking for a second it's
not about courage it's about my my
virtue in general you see I'm such a
virtuous person that when I see
injustice okay when I see racism
homophobia ethnocentrism when I hear
someone making degrading remarks about
other races and ethnicities Asians
Native Americans etc I can't help myself
but speak out is he every every bone in
my body is screaming out against it I
just can't stop myself
sometimes I wish I could you know
I'm putting myself on the line so often
speaking out against injustice but so
this is really just I I cannot stop
myself from doing it and and and someone
needs to so thank God thank God for that
thank God for me thank God for you know
everybody in that video to a lesser
extent and thank God for you that you
were able to watch me alright let's move
on to your daily cancelation but before
we do speaking of you know let's let's
keep the Nspire let's keep the
inspiration going I want to tell you
about the readers pass over at daily
wire.com there's so much going on in the
world these days a lot of news and the
unfortunate thing is that you when
you're when you're getting the news from
the mainstream media you have to you
have to sift sift through all of the
leftist bias and the narrative building
that goes on which can be very difficult
to do which is why you need to get a
reader's pass today from daily wire.com
do weed access to exclusive op eds from
your podcast host as well as guest
writers in-depth analysis from our daily
wire reporters on top of our regular
breaking news as well all of it very
good this membership tier is already a
bargain at $3 a month but you can get it
now for 99 cents for the first month you
also get access to our mobile app you
receive push notifications for breaking
news and special content you can join
our community of daily wire readers who
can comment and and discuss the content
that's mobile and free access to all of
our daily wire news exclusive op-eds and
more on our mobile app all for the low
price of $1 and best of all your dollars
are getting you the news you need
without the leftist spin so go to daily
wire.com slash subscribe and join today
okay today for our daily cancellation we
have one of the most deserving
cancellations I have yet carried out
this one is on coach Mike Gundy of
Oklahoma State University he is
cancelled he's cancelled for what he did
to avoid being cancelled so he tried to
swerve around the cancellation but he
didn't realize there's another cancel
truck coming and then there was a
head-on collision of in this analogy
isn't really going away but you get the
point so background on this Gundy face
backlash from the left and the media
who tried to organize and foment the
cancel mob because he recently went
fishing wearing a shirt with the oen
logo one American News conservative news
network
and apparently wearing this shirt to go
fishing with a news organizations logo
is an unforgivable sin now the the
leftists were crying some of his players
were crying about it everybody was
crying and finally Gundy recorded the
requisite hostage video let's let's take
a look at that I had a great meeting
with our team today our players express
their feelings as individuals and his
team members they helped me see through
their eyes how the t-shirt affected
their hearts okay could we just stop
there for one site I'm gonna play the
entire thing this is like another this
is round two of the cringe challenge how
the t-shirt affected their hearts how
did he even say that with a straight
face how many takes how many takes did
you have to do to get that line out with
a straight face how the t-shirt affected
their hearts alright let's let's just
finish watching it once I learned how
that Network felt about black lives
matter I was disgusted and knew it was
completely unacceptable to me I want to
apologize to all members of our team
former players and their families for
the pain and discomfort that has been
caused over the last two days black
lives matter to me
our players matter to me these meetings
with our team have been eye-opening and
will result in positive changes for
Oklahoma State football I sincerely hope
the Oklahoma State family near and far
will accept my humble apology as we move
forward pain and discomfort
pain and discomfort caused by a t-shirt
and this is a football coach a football
coach can you imagine how a football
coach 30 years ago would have responded
if his players were crying about a
t-shirt they didn't like I mean even
when I was in high school you know I
just can't imagine as a kid going up to
my football coach and saying coach I
just want to tell you that shirt you're
wearing it's really hurtful to me it's
it's it's really offensive and hurtful
your t-shirt I really don't like it it
really hurts my feelings the response
from my coach would have involved a
string of profanities a number of choice
insults all of which would be
questioning my manhood in no uncertain
terms and then I would have been invited
to work off my my emotions by doing
push-ups and and in running Hills and
maybe it would have been suggested that
some form of you know some form tackling
drills would help me drills where I
stand in for the tackling dummy that's
how a football coach is supposed to
respond that's really the whole point of
a football coach the whole point
especially especially for you know kids
in college the whole point is for them
to be tough and mean and not care about
your feelings that's the great service
that they provide and have always
provided to young men if even now
they're apologizing I mean if football
coaches are now apologizing
to these ridiculous babies who are
offended by a news channels logo then
we're doomed there's there's just no
hope
now let me try to help out my Gundy here
let me offer the correction that she
should have offered to his players for
their own sake this is what he should
have said and this is what anyone should
say when the mob demands an apology so
here's the script okay here it is and
this is my hostage video this is my
public apology video sort of a form that
you can use in the future if you're ever
in a position where public apology is
being demanded of you this is what it
should look like it's Allegan you can
have your own variation of it but this
should be the basic idea hello it has
come to my attention that many of you
are offended by something that I did or
said I have listened to your concerns I
have thought deeply about them I want
you to know from my heart after careful
consideration that I don't care about
your feelings at all or your fragile
egos I'm glad you were offended I hope
you suffer more offenses in the future I
will laugh at you while you suffer them
I would in fact rather jump into a wood
chipper then apologize to you dumb whiny
babies I am NOT sorry I will never be
sorry and there's nothing you can ever
do or say that will make me pretend to
be sorry
in conclusion kiss my ass thank you
that's the correct response okay that
that is not just in this situation but
in any situation the public apology as a
genre should be abolished abolish the
public apology private apologies are
fine I'm not saying never apologize for
anything if you do something wrong
to someone if you hurt someone in some
way and you feel genuine remorse for it
you know that you were wrong then yes
you should apologize to that person you
go to that person individually privately
you pull them aside and you say I'm
really sorry for that you know I'll try
to be better in the future so whatever
you want to say but apology as spectacle
apology as content for the public to
consume apology is due to whole masses
of strangers almost all of whom were
completely unaffected by
ever you did or said that was supposedly
offensive and probably weren't even
aware of it until you apologized for it
that needs to be done that needs to end
that needs to not exist anymore the only
thing you should ever publicly apologize
for anymore is publicly apologizing for
something I will accept the public
apology for that so Mike Gundy owes us
another public apology for the apology
that he just gave us which which was
which was which hurt me because of how
embarrassing it was to watch and it also
hurts me to see football which is a
cherished American institution being
destroyed by these oversensitive
thin-skinned babies who are now being
coddled by the coaches that are supposed
to be supposed to be getting them into
shape so yeah you want to apologize to
that that could be the last public
apology anyone ever issues after that
we're done there is no occasion for it
I've said this before even if I say
something that I know is that that later
I realize is wrong even if I say
something that is offensive and I later
on I on second thought I think oh that
was offensive I'm still not gonna
apologize for it I won't do it it's not
gonna happen because you're not owed an
apology I hate to say it you whoever is
out there watching this right now what
do you owed an apology for what what
could I possibly say that would make me
Oh an apology to you and some that I'm
not your I'm not hurting you or
affecting you in any way the most I
could do is just give an opinion that
you don't like even if it's a terrible
opinion okay so you heard an opinion you
don't like get over it just move on with
your life he'll owe you an apology you
aren't really hurt by that if you were
really hurt by it then grow up
same goes for me okay if you're ever out
in public and you didn't you say you
give an opinion and and you know you
later realize that oh I shouldn't have
said that you don't apologize to me when
you apologizing to me for what
my Gundy apologizing to me for he does a
public apologies apologizing everybody
the hell is he apologizing me I'm not
involved in this the whole thing is
ridiculous and it just it just needs to
stop and it's it's of course it's not
sincere and genuine anyway I mean
extracting an apology from someone that
you know they don't mean you're forcing
them to say it what does that accomplish
other than well I know what it
accomplishes for you as a person
extracting the apology makes you feel
powerful but that's that's the reason
why even you know even if my Gundy
decided that he was really wrong and
remorseful for wearing a shirt which he
didn't okay I don't believe that for a
second but even if he did you know you
still don't apologize because the this
is the demand for the apology is in bad
faith these are people just want to feel
power over you and just want to see you
dancing to their tune and you can't do
that so we need to be done with that no
more public apologies if you have
apology if you have an apology for
someone offer to them in private and you
know what if you offer someone a private
apology and then they say in order to
accept this I need you to say that
publicly to everybody I need you to
record a hostage video and you'll put it
on Twitter I need you to say in front of
a camera then if someone says that to
you if that's the response to a private
apology you offered them then then you
should retract the private apology and
say nevermind I'm not sorry screw you
because then then forget it that's
someone who's not worthy of an apology
if they're worthy of an apology and it's
a sincere apology there's a sincere
moment of opportunity for contrition
they will be happy with your private
apology and they will move on and
speaking to move on we will wrap it up
there for the show thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]